hi have you heard the story of Joseph
Smith start with Jesus okay where likes
Jesus what we meant to say was do you I
think that a lot of people think it's so
easy to be religious mourning but are
you doing oh no worries hey how you
doing do you believe in Jesus Christ oh
that's alright okay good luck
not at all I want to talk to them but I
don't want them to think I'm hitting on
them figuring out my outfits are y'all
doing this morning any girls updated it
in my six months of being missionary for
the Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints my faith has been tested all time
well so we we actually don't smoke
that's part of our church we don't smoke
and we don't drink and that's why
Mormons are the best-looking yeah oh
don't look to your right there's a big
old sign Stone even bow my god you not
to look there I go oh I do want to help
people people just don't seem to always
want to be helped oh hi how are you
doing would you like to know about the
one true church about my day you know I
miss my mom and dad and I miss my three
older brothers mark Jared and Brian and
my three younger brothers Luke Paul Gary
however despite all this you know the
end of these two years at least to have
my gal Linda to come home to did you
propose before you left no I was gonna
wait till the mission was done and then
after I got into dental school and stuff
right we mean right
No I had a girl back in Vegas but
Heavenly Father had another plan for her
and she married a returning missionary
I've been on my mission here in Los
Angeles for almost two years since then
I only have a couple of months left and
I don't really want it to end
[Music]
for me faith is like music you just have
to follow the beat and also be a good
singer and if you're not a good singer
you could play the tambourine or
something or just be quiet and listen to
the Holy Spirit hi there
have you heard about the restoration the
gospel good morning sir
maybe we just kind of leave a pamphlet
on your door if you don't mind thanks so
much
hello must be a little breezy getting
you on one muscle there you go whoa you
know something may be wrong maybe let's
try this I know we should find an
investigator but I really don't want
another door in my face
maybe we shouldn't lead with Joseph
Smith as a prophet what do you lean with
you don't lean but Joseph Smith's
apartment like that's the best part
coming love hi we're for the Church of
Jesus Christ of Latter day so usually
Star Wars fan star wars no not really
why um what about a Britney Spears me
but is like ready what if the Old
Testament is like baby one more time and
the New Testament is oops I did it again
the Book of Mormon is Britney oh I'm a
slave for you Britney yes when it's
finally about the dance do you mind if
we come in and talk about the Book of
Mormon this is guerrilla holiday oh so
you guys are Christian right yeah it's
in the name the Church of Jesus Christ
of Latter day Saints what makes you any
different from all the other churches
out there we don't drink alcohol okay I
haven't drank for about a month now so
hey that's awesome yeah I feel I feel
fresh I feel rejuvenated we also don't
use tobacco
well I smoke but I'm trying to cut back
self-improvement is so important that
it's just no caffeine no caffeine it's
so how do you wake up in the morning
well you know as it says in the Doctrine
and Covenants you know we're not really
supposed live in one oh well it's kind
of like the liner notes on an album so
there's these words of wisdom that say
there are certain harmful substances
that we should have seen from it's even
in the new tab
no he not that ye or a temple of God and
that the Spirit of God dwelleth in you
okay so my body's like a temple I like
that
what's your stance on the LGBT community
what's an LGBT the gay people why would
you want to know about that why do you
listen to so much Britney then like
dance yeah I like men oh dang hope I
didn't send him any mixed signals or
anything I touched his hand
Zeca can't see I can't see we should
teach her I got I got no no no yeah I
mean yeah there's gonna be more losses
Atwoods it's just how this works but
oops sorry I just think busy it's been
really hard this week I miss my mom at
the end I miss my brothers and I miss my
girlfriend at NIDA
I don't know what I'm doing I want this
mirror to help me do better I just don't
think I'm doing it I don't really want
to do this anymore
hey Ezra yeah dad hey buddy you trying
to get out of sight mass on me oh it's
tough being away from your family I know
stuff for me when I first got here you
got a hold onto your testimony
[Music]
no that's what will keep you strong you
know what helps you hold on to your
testimony better than anything
singing about God hey Boggs get your
guitar come on in here
[Music]
that's how it is right you know just
when you're out of faith that's when
your friends show up
I'm keep spreading the word god yeah bad
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
taste guys you're welcome
how you doing dogs um my dad just died
want to see more yeah
[Music]